stop Democrats calling out the media and
their own party yes you heard me
correctly first Nancy Pelosi is urging
the press to stop the round-the-clock
coverage of President Trump what I wish
that the press would spend a lot more
time on what we need to do here to meet
the needs of American people instead of
morning noon and night allegations
against the president I think you'd have
more viewers or readers that people
would address concerns that people have
rather than just this ongoing ongoing
coverage of what's what's current with
the president from one day to the next
and outgoing Missouri Senator Claire
McCaskill is telling Democrats to stop
focusing so much on gender politics I
think one of the mistakes that we make
as a party is spending too much time
talking about the gender thing you know
we are a party of all kinds of people
and you know white men white
working-class men have traditionally
been a huge part of our party we have
lost a lot of them and one of those
reasons is we've had a tendency to talk
maybe too much about gender I'm gonna
see
well I always agree I always feel that
identity politics is a divisive divisive
thing Republicans aren't announcing hey
we're the party of men join us dams
however do have some noted voices like
Gillibrand saying you know we're the
party of women and I do think that even
women get put off by because I think
it's patron up patronizing patronizing
who cares anyway you know you're heading
down a wrong path when even Pelosi says
don't go there
I mean she's actually in a weird way
defending Trump she's trying to give the
media in idiot intervention because
their big turn they've been idiot eyes
but I had their their distaste for Trump
but I'm wondering why she's doing it now
and it's interesting to me I love her
coat do you think it's because of what
what Jesse brought up that she knows
that there she knows a lot of people in
DC who are guilty of the same thing and
payoffs for sexual harassment
paid for by us the tax pair do you think
that that dad that she knows that this
is just gonna go down a really bad path
I think that she well I think is that
she has been saying these types of
things but you know but she wasn't a
leader right she had no power no one
listened to her and now people are
actually listening to her yeah I I think
she's wants to start off on health care
and media wants to start off on scandal
and she's like a terrible TV executive
she's like hey guys in the media don't
cover the Trump scandals cover health
care policy I mean come on I think you
know they won on health care and she
wants it to be covered it's probably how
to Mitch McConnell thinks mitch is like
you know we're confirming judges tax
cuts we're doing this on trade and you
guys are just covering the Trump Tower
meeting can I get a little credit here I
understand that with Claire McCaskill
it's funny being a red state Democrat
it's kind of like it's kind of like
riding a bull you're only gonna be on
for like one term maybe two terms and
the only reason you got there is either
someone died there's a major scandal or
like they nominate a checkpoint of other
government or like some guy likes to
date teenage girls like that's the only
reason you're there so just hold on
tight and then when they're gone they're
out of Congress or other Senate they go
a Democrats there's a whole country out
there and trust me you can't play the
gender card all the time why don't you
on special report well I mean I think
that was an interesting comment by
Pelosi I think you guys are right I
think she wants people to cover real
issues because I think that's what she
wants the Democrats to be on in a head
of the 2020 race and people won't be
able to say it's just about the
Democrats scandal investigate Trump but
you know I was thinking about this and I
one thing that strikes me I just want to
mention quickly is the end of the Weekly
Standard because here you have a
conservative magazine who's actually
doing reporting and could be critical of
Trump and they get pushed out of
business they lose subscribers same
thing happened the national view after
they were critical well and so now you
get a situation where why well I do but
I
I stay away okay but here's here's my
point that I think that right now in the
sort of conservative media bubble if you
have if you are pro Trump that's all
people want to hear they just want our
firm Trump is okay everything is
everything is coming by attacks from the
liberal press that's not what's going on
what do you think is going on well my
point was about specifically about the
Weekly Standard which was a business
decision I don't think yeah because they
were losing so but that's not but that's
actually not it okay but that's not
we're here to talk about Emily um when
Claire McCaskill is saying we've got to
do something more you can't just talk to
women in the party but do the
Republicans also need to talk about
women I mean they have they lost women
in the 2018 midterm elections and
they've got some ground to make up yes I
think there was aggressive messaging by
the left in the midterm elections
towards women but I think it would be
more significant strides would be
achieved if it wasn't so term specific
like that's when you lose everyone
that's when you alienate everyone that's
not a woman right I went to a diversity
event recently but it was never called
that and the planner said that the whole
commitment was for diversity there was a
certain percentage and whatever but it
was never it was just a certain finance
what was it called that felt show so the
point is that it allowed everyone to
just relax rather than be confined to
some type of oh I am this and so I'm
going to answer to this call I
respectfully disagree with your point
about the conservative bubble because I
think there's a significant faction that
isn't just a knee-jerk pro-trump that
supporters in the conservative bubble
and then on the lezzy people are saying
that's what it looks like I mean by the
way on the point that you're making
about the women play yeah there was a I
think it's a 23-point gender gap in the
midterms right you look at what happened
I think they're like 30-something
freshmen Democratic women coming in in
the next Congress and that and the
Republicans lost
they went down from like 20 to 39